The 18
year old son
of NBA
superstar LeBron
James suffering cardiac arrest.
It happened during a workout
at the University of Southern California,
where Bronny James plays basketball
The terrifying incident
was quickly filed,
followed by wild speculation
and conspiracy theories.
Elon Musk today
suggesting the COVID vaccine
caused Ronnie's cardiac arrest,
tweeting,
We can not ascribe everything
to the vaccine,
but by the same token,
we cannot ascribe nothing.
Myocarditis is a known side effect.
The only question is whether it is rare
or common.
What we do know
answers to some of those questions,
and I'm going to get to that in a moment.
We also do not know if James suffered
from myocarditis.
I do want to go first to Natasha Chen.
She is at the USC
campus in Los Angeles tonight.
And Natasha,
what can you tell us about how Brian
is doing tonight?
Well, Erin, his
family is
not releasing much in terms of details,
but did confirm this happened
at the Galen Center
right behind me
where the USC basketball team practices
it happened Monday morning.
He is out of the ICU now
and in stable condition.
The family also said
that the medical staff
here were able to treat him
and taken to a hospital.
Their statement reads in part,
LeBron and Savannah
wish to publicly send their deepest
thanks
and appreciation to the USC medical
and athletics staff
for their incredible work and dedication
to the safety of their athletes.
Now, the James family was seen in public
just about two weeks ago
at the MTV Awards,
where LeBron James was accepting an award
standing on stage
with his wife and children,
whom he called his greatest blessing,
particularly saying
how proud he is of his two sons
and their own basketball journey.
Bronny James, 18 years
old, just committed to USC this spring.
The team had announced
that they were going on a European tour
starting August 5th.
That's likely
what they were practicing for.
Bronny James is ranked
number 20 in ESPN's class of 2023.
His father telling The Athletic last year
that his goal is to stay in the NBA
so he can play alongside his son.
And now,
of course,
all of that
may be affected by
what happened yesterday Erin.
All right, Natasha,
thank you very much for that. Update.
And I want to bring in Dr.
Matthew Martinez now.
He's the director
of Atlantic Health System
Sports Cardiology
at Morristown Medical Center.
He's also a consultant cardiologist
with the NBA Players Association,
the NFL, the NHL and Major League Soccer.
So, Dr.
Martinez,
you know,
more about
a terrifying situation like this
than almost anyone and sadly, often
a very deadly situation.
Ronnie James is extremely young.
18 years old going into cardiac arrest.
It's his first season of basketball
at USC.
Can you explain how something like
this happens to somebody so young
Sure.
You know, it's a rare event.
So exercise as medicine,
it is safe to participate in sports.
We think in this age
group, under the age of 35,
somewhere between one 50,100
thousand individuals.
But as you say,
it's usually the young, otherwise healthy
athletes.
And we know
that some athletes are at higher
risk than other men, more so than women,
African-American men of the highest risk.
In fact,
African-American basketball players
get behind.
So if you're playing basketball,
football or soccer,
those are the highest of sports
men more than women.
And African-American males believe that
these are rare events.
No question.
And so,
you know, in this context,
Elon Musk comes out today
weighing in on the COVID vaccine,
saying that
it could have been responsible
for what happened to Bronny.
He tweeted,
We cannot ascribe
everything to the vaccine,
but by the same token,
we cannot ascribe nothing.
Myocarditis is a known side effect.
The only question is
whether it's rare or common.
Now, obviously, there there are
a lot of studies have been done on this.
But it does touch on fears
that a lot of people have. Dr..
What's your response
to what Musk is saying?
My response is that myocarditis
is definitely a cause of sudden death,
but not a common cause.
And if you look at the data
which we published
last year
of lay athletes
as well as professional athletes,
who then causes myocarditis
not under 1% of the time.
So
myocarditis before COVID myocarditis
will occur after COVID,
but it is one of the causes,
but not a common cause.
And the vaccines
based on data from Yale occurrence
causes myocarditis
or inflammation of the heart muscle.
Somewhere around
30 out of every 100,000 vaccines
involving the virus.
The illness causes it twice as much,
not 600,000.
So it's still better,
safer to have the vaccine
than it is to have proven itself.
All of that happens
usually in the first 21 days.
Based on what to do there
you have the vaccine six months ago
shouldn't be involved.
Right.
Which I think is important
that you point out.
And also those statistics
that, yes,
it can cause it, but the virus itself
causes it
more often than the vaccine
from the studies thus far.
You know,
Ronnie
James is the second
USC basketball player in the past year
to suffer cardiac arrest.
And of course,
we all know about DeMar Hamlin
from the Buffalo Bills
collapsed of that football game.
He was 24 years old.
His heart just stopped
of obviously he's recovering.
In the case of Hamlin.
There was wild speculation again
about the role of the COVID vaccine.
It was unfounded, doctor,
but it was very prevalent.
We all heard it.
Do you have any hesitation at this point?
About recommending the
COVID vaccine to young men
to who we are currently recommending?
I don't have any of the data now.
My mind is quite strong
for the safety of this
and the potential benefit
related to the vaccine.
So I think us
should be
commended for the emergency action plan
and the utility of CPR.
Actually, the message was
that you can't predict that,
but when it happens, you better be.
And I want to ask you
about one other thing,
because obviously, as I mentioned,
you work with the Players
Association, NBA, NHL, NFL,
Major League Soccer.
In this context,
LeBron James himself
has been extremely vocal
about wanting to play in the NBA
with Bronny.
Here's what he said
I need to be on the floor of my boy
I got to be on the floor over Bronny
Obviously you're not treating him,
so you're not able to give
a definitive answer.
But
do you think that could still be possible
given what has happened?
Possible for sure.
Well, the diagnosis matters
and we can develop a plan
and then we can talk about prognosis.
We are actually publishing data
that those with genetic cards
that anybody ends up having a plan can.
Yes.
We see as an expert,
we come up with an exercise plan
and we develop that plan for safety
to all the stakeholders.
Absolutely.
This is an opportunity
for Randy to simply
we have to decide
what's wrong with the therapy
before we can tell you a secret
All right.
Well, thank you very much, Dr. Martinez.
I appreciate your time.
Thanks for having me.